it's being described as the worst
humanitarian crisis in Mozambique's
history heavy flooding and prolonged
bouts of rain are compounding the
destruction wreaked by cyclone edye last
week the storm and flood waters not only
engulfed roads and bridges they also
wiped out communications networks across
the region and many of Edie's victims
are once again finding themselves in
danger this mother is one of hundreds of
thousands who lost their home she's
worried about her newborn as food
supplies in the shelter run low they do
and since last night I haven't eaten
anything yesterday I saw that food was
running out I went and asked and they
told me that food was over and until now
I've had none that's because the floods
and heavy rain which followed in the
storms wake are hindering eight workers
efforts in some areas flood waters are
meters deep
most rural areas remain cut off from
help you us are also working around the
clock to save lives many victims are
still trapped on rooftops trees and
other remote areas and the region is
bracing for more heavy rain in the
coming days
flooding has become the biggest threat
Mozambique is facing right now a spring
in jameelah sewer he's the emergency
response manager for the Red Cross and
byra which has been especially hard-hit
good morning to you Jaime the UN is is
calling this the worst storm disaster to
hit Africa in decades
what's the situation where you are
well it's still raining do that and it's
gonna rain for a couple days more so we
are on the second disaster in a few a
few days and it's actually going to get
worse potentially we know that cyclone
and I hit us directly in beta and that
the it continued on towards the Bob way
it's an amount of water so the flood
disaster is another disaster on top of
the cyclone damage so we're keeping
visibility on both and our focus for the
operation right now is immediate
life-saving activities search-and-rescue
making sure people get food blankets
shelter water everything they need to
stay alive because this is where our
focus is at the moment okay getting
resources to keep people alive where are
people going right now with so much of
byra floated and uninhabitable
we're setting up accommodation centers
there have been 37 established in Baia
and that number is expecting to increase
that's for the cyclone affected
population for those who are flood
affected we're also moving them to
accommodation centers to keep them set
up we have Rapid Response Team going out
in helicopters this morning to support
moving people from their houses from the
top of their roofs on their houses and
in from the trees to put them on safe
and dry land we're doing everything we
can with our aerial assessments to make
sure we're going to not at risk places
for future flooding that are completely
dry and where we can get access to them
quickly this is one of the main
challenges for all of us here okay it
certainly sounds very challenging the
Jamey our unit of area are you managing
to find safe and dry areas that are
going to be safe even with as you said
the new rains coming on
yes first this is non-negotiable point
we absolutely need to find low-risk safe
dry areas so we have international
experts in shelter from around the world
that are supporting on this the Red
Cross is a co-lead of the shelter
strategy here and helping to ensure that
we're finding that dry land and setting
up the places where our people need to
be Jamie thanks very much for coming in
being with us today Jamie LeSueur and
all the best view from emergency
response with the Red Cross